oh yeah be jealous because I am in
Hawaii with this crew right here
you guys been enjoying Hawaii while
you're here did anyone bring their
families oh wait you did please I always
do I maybe meet Minnie uh yeah she went
to breakfast Minnie and Mickey and she's
not scared at all because last year she
was only a year and a half and Mickey
she thought was a cow because it's black
she sang with Moana I sing with Moana it
was amazing her namesake she's in the
Disney Family she's gonna know you know
I think
I accidentally named my dog
my dog the idol crew was definitely
living it up Island style all in prep
for Hawaii week which kicks off this
Sunday on ABC we usually have a top 24
and now there's 26. it's 26 because we
literally could not paired out we were
like asking all the producers is this
okay I know you guys have done this for
20 one Seasons but we can't send these
people
okay can't we just have three top number
ones we're throwing off such amazing
talent to the point now where we're
relieved because America takes over the
two-night event includes two new mentors
soul singer Alan Stone and Noah Cyrus
Lionel Luke and Katie are so kind and
generous I mean I've known Katie since I
was a little girl and she also invited
me out on her witness tour in 2017
anytime I get to see her it's great I
love her latest record obviously it's
something in the blood with my family
what are they feeding though outside of
his family I think it's in the DNA of
course I couldn't leave Hawaii without
auditioning myself Aloha Style you guys
think if I learn how to play the ukulele
I have a chance this season on idol no
oh yeah
[Music]